Samuel lives here and a lot of people
ask me when they're starting out to
invest in property what is better HMO or
just a straightforward to sing all that
so in this video I'm going to be doing a
HMOs verse single let's pros and cons so
stay tuned so I'm just gonna get it out
there right up for the record all I
think that HMOs are better than single
lats usually now that's not to say that
every HMO is better than every single
that it's not to say that just because
it's a HMO means it's a good deal and
just because it's a single that means
it's a bad deal I'm gonna give you a
balanced view of the pros and cons
though firstly let me give you the
negatives of HMOs so the negatives of
HMOs number one is they're usually more
expensive to buy and get into because
not only other properties more expensive
usually but also you know you have got
setup costs such as furniture fire door
smoke alarms you might get a license to
the property so there are there are
setup costs now the way that I buy HMOs
is probably very different to most
people my setup costs are extremely low
there are going to be some substantial
set of costs so typically speaking to
buy an HMO you're gonna need a mini-mom
in your bank of 35,000 pounds that's
like a minimum just to get into the HMO
market HMO multi let whatever we're
talking about when you rent a property
out on a room-by-room basis here
so that's the negative to HMOs another
negative about HMOs is that the
management of it so I would recommend
don't manage it yourself get someone to
do it but you're gonna need to find
someone to do it so there's you're gonna
need a particular person in your power
team who's gonna be good at managing
HMOs anyone could manage your single
that you could just be at any high
street Lane agent sometimes a lot of my
students are properties no one manages
it they do it themselves just from a
distance and the phone might ring every
three or four months you know so so the
management of HMO is a lot more which of
course can be overcome by a good
property manager but that that's all the
cons in regards to legislation changes I
don't I can't imagine them bringing in
any more legislation for HMOs they
already have brought
all the legislation I think they're
gonna bring in so another this is I
guess a good thing about buying HMOs I
think it's quite safe all the
legislators we're boring it's not like
serviced accommodation whereby it's
unregulated and it could suddenly change
HMO is already regulated so if you do
properly that there's not a risk of that
but it is gonna cost you 35 grand as a
minimum and you're going to need to find
out a good hmm manager in the area to
let it so that's the cons the pros of
buying a Haitian are over a single that
are just obvious when you buy a normal
house a normal single that you get paid
once by that person who all that family
that's living there whereas when you buy
a hey cello property you're getting paid
four five six times because you've got
multiple people living in the property
which means that you've got a
substantial more amount of rent if you
look at my portfolio I mean the bulk of
my income certainly for my residential
portfolio comes from HMOs even though
I've got just as many single exit HMOs
if you wiped out my single that someone
portfolio it wouldn't affect me anywhere
near as much as it would if you knocked
out the HMOs so they're a brilliant cash
cow typically HMO is gonna earn you a
profit in your back pocket of anywhere
from seven hundred pounds right up to
two thousand pounds a month depending on
where and what it is so brilliant cash
cow you can't retire off three single
that properties it just doesn't happen
but I know loads and loads of people who
have retired or become completely
financially free off the back of just
buying three HMOs now let me talk a
little about single s advantage and
disadvantage what obviously as we've
said the disadvantage to single let's is
the income is usually pretty poor I'm
not talking about the return I'm talking
about the income so an average single
that might make you two or three hundred
pounds a month
and you're gonna need what ten of those
just to earn an average salary ten I saw
a lot of properties I know people that
own 50 properties and their income is
not that great because the the single
that house they've got just aren't
generating that much income that's a big
con a big Pro to single that is the
mortgage ability on them it's so easy to
just buy a single at house pretty much
anybody you can be just finish
university 21 years old not
to money you know I know a lot of people
in that kind of stages in life that are
just going and buying single debt
properties whether it's a HMO you're
going to need you know a particular type
of lender it's a little bit more
complicated so what I often advise is a
by a single at first as your first
property and then once you've got a
little bit of landlord experience you've
got a little bit of money coming in then
move on to HMOs for your second third
and fourth properties that that's
probably generally a good idea
but what I would say if you're buying a
single net property don't buy a house
for like 150 200 grands and rent it out
for six hundred pounds a month you just
should not do that you're going to buy
to single that get a single let this
giving you a really high return on
investment because there's no direct
correlation between the house price and
the rent a single that property there's
200 grands might give you a rent of 700
but then if you buy a single it for a
hundred grams the rent only 600 just a
tiny bit less which means your return is
a lot better always make sure if you buy
in single less I would roll the buy
single it for 60 grand rent out for 500
and get a really high return as my first
one and then move on to HMOs so that's a
little bit of a pros and cons if you've
got comments questions please put them
below I'd also love to hear your
experience and what your thoughts are on
what's better HMOs versus single let's
comment your thoughts ideas below and
I'll try my best to read every single
one thanks so much I'll see you next
time
you